hey gina
you know any scalpers i want to ask rosa
to go to the rihanna concert with me but
it's sold out
okay two points to make here first
rihanna
you and then rihanna
what's your second point she's got a
type which is really
anyone but you yeah that was my
ex-wife's type too
look a rihanna concert's a pretty big
swing man
i don't know she's into watching old
movies cool
where would i find a place to chose old
movies oh yeah
just go on the internet and search for
the phrase i want to buy two movie
tickets
for a girl who doesn't like me great
thank you hey rosa rosa um
i i just happen to notice that uh
there's an old movie festival
play at the film forum this week
you want to go sure cool
awesome there's a bunch of movie options
i'll probably just go
with something classic like citizen kane
citizen kane is terrible pick a good
movie
good call smart i'll do it
i'll pick a better movie than citizen
kane
so what movie did you get us tickets to
oh well just to be safe
i bought tickets to all of them just to
be safe what does that mean
i don't know uh i didn't want to mess up
because you're
sort of opinionated you think i'm
opinionated
okay here's an opinion for you you're a
bad judge of character and your shirt
looks like vomit
so we can go see north by northwest
we're not seeing a movie together good
call
smart keep it fresh
[Applause]
vision the woman you love
the one you work with the scary one with
the black hair rosa
yes she doesn't love you back she will
never love you back
say thank you charles she just told you
your future
thank you i just got a doa on bessemer
street you're the primary you're in
charge take diaz and peralta
yes my fantasy threesome
of cops on a case what's wrong with the
way i dress you know some people
might say that all the black leather
kind of makes you look like a
evil villain not me i think you look
like a sexy motorcycle
boy pull it together yeah we need to
soften up your look
my wife and charles's mom donated some
clothes
your wife and boyle's mom are both blind
[Music]
i look like arsenio so it's
perfect that's actually my wedding suit
no yes
no that's
great perfect you look beautifully
appropriate for court great advice
dummies i look like a psycho up there
yes you have to pull it together that's
not helping it's what sartre says to me
when i'm nervous
rosa i think you're nervous of course
i'm nervous
what do you think was a problem we just
assumed you were a terrifying human
being with a short fuse
but if the problem is that you're
nervous that's where charles boyle
lives baby i can help you just need to
go to your happy place
what's that sounds stupid oh everyone's
happy place is different
for me i just imagine i'm slurping up
the world's longest piece of linguine
it just keeps going and going every 20
feet of noodle there's a sauce change
i'm in my happy place right now mmm
pesto
mmm carbonara great now i'm starving
i owe you one boyle thank you dinner
tomorrow night for baldi's that's all
you can eat linguini
yes oh my boyfriend's coming too your
what friend now
hang on i have a toast i am thankful to
have
someone in my life who gives me a reason
to get out of bed every morning
and i hope that my relationship with
this person
will only grow more intimate
who are you talking about um
hitchcock
hey my flight is at eight tonight it's
domestic maybe i'll be safe if i get to
the airport five hours early
five no way you gotta do seven seven
minimum
seven i knew it yeah why are you going
on a singles cruise i thought you're
into rosa
well i am but i've begun to feel like
there's a slight
chance rosa may not love me back hey how
about we grab some dinner tonight
just you and me that's nice i don't like
you as a person but i'm just not
interested in you
romantically coolio hey what say you we
grab a drink
you're starting to make this weird i'm
not into you that way and i have a
boyfriend
gotcha raincheck a rose
for rosa listen to me the healthy thing
for you to do
is move on so we both
decided the healthy thing for me to do
is to just move on
i need an ambulance boiled down
what happened not my dad you saved my
life
died my
god oh my
god i have to tell you guys something
even though i got shot in the butt sorry
i'd rather be here spending christmas
with all of you
than on some stupid singles cruz and i
mean that from the bottom of my butt
again sorry ow shut up jake
will's a hero and so is his butt
rosa why are you sequestered over by
this old cell phone
i'm avoiding boyle and his truth bombs i
sometimes worry i'm going to become
you keep saying he wants to talk to me
i'm afraid he's going to tell me he
loves me or
proposed marriage or something oh my god
that makes me kind of want to cry
he dove in front of those bullets for me
i can't be mean to him
i watched him make coffee for 28 minutes
this morning
hey i need to talk to you oh it's
happening
remember when i took those bullets for
you okay let's do this
i think you're sweet how did you know it
was you
when i jumped in front of those bullets
i didn't know who i was protecting
i just saw a gun and a nypd vest and so
i dove on instinct
you've been extra nice to me because you
thought i'd risk my life for you but
i only did what every good cop would do
when you finally go out with me and you
will it'll be because i do things that
only charles boyle would do
um actually i have a coat in here it's
uh
it's like it's actually i see it it's
like it's blue it's like right
i want to take vivian somewhere romantic
tonight how about this
graziolos for the porco digestivo meal
it's a culinary tour of a pig's
digestive tract uh
pig bung gelato for two anyone oh that's
up
weekend crew
i feel sad for you i love my desk buddy
sometimes detective kearns and i leave
presents for each other
yeah well lohank's a stubble monkey i
hate him anna's face garbage
why don't you just tell him to stop
shaving at his desk he denies even doing
it i don't know why
next time i catch him shaving i'm gonna
punch him so hard in the mouth he bites
his own heart
could that be why tonight's doing it oh
yeah you could be right yeah
rosa look oh hank is shaving right now
[Applause]
hey
call an ambulance i'm gonna do some
stuff to him or we give him a taste of
his own medicine
we fill his locker with shaving cream
and loose hair
i like it i cannot believe i am
considering a non-violent option
and i know just where to get a bundle of
loose hair
oh yeah wow i think if you're smiling
like cold-blooded vengeance
and now the ps the resistance
a magnificent bag of hair
oh this is disgusting it's perfect
oh check check this out
tom selleck parked my chopper on the
beach
i'm a bully goat
oh i think i swallowed a bunch of
stranger hair ugh
it's fun today although i'm pretty sure
i caught some form of face lice from
that bag of hair
being a cop is dangerous although i knew
that going in yeah it was fun
hey you want to grab a drink oh shoot i
would but i'm eating vivian for that
romantic pig colon dinner
hey rosa i want to apologize i haven't
been much fun to hang out with over the
last year or so on account of all the
asking you out and smelling your hair
and staring at you from point blank
range
yeah you were a real weirdo but you're
pretty cool now that you're in love with
someone else
have a nice dinner oh we will they make
a sorbet out of the tail
see ya
you